Uh, let's go next to our caller from the two
eight one area code. Who's calling today from
two eight one.
Hello? Is that me?
Yes it is.
Okay. Hello David. My name's Racio. How are
you doing today?
Good, thank you.
Um, I wanted to ask you just a more fun question,
if that's all right. So I'm a a major at university
of Houston. And as someone who's really interested
in linguistics, I was wondering if whenever
you've interacted with Spanish speakers, either
from the United States, you know, Mexico more
North America, do they have trouble understanding
your Argentinian accent at all?
No, because I modulate my, uh, my vocabulary
so that it is easier for them to understand.
So instead of saying Vos I say do and I conjugate
the way that they would be used to. So I mean,
I'm modulating my Spanish when I know that
I'm speaking to a non Argentinian
and when you like, so I think the, the double
LA like, uh, it has a Y noise.
Oh yeah. I don't do that. I don't do that.
I don't, I don't do that. That's too ingrained.
I can't do that.
See, for me, like I like, I have a hard time
understanding the Argentinian accent just
because of that, because it's such a different
noise than the, the wind noise that I'm used
to.
That's interesting. Yeah. I'm watching a show
on Netflix right now called in English. They've
translated it as money heist. It's a Spanish
show like from Spain and there's a lot of
Spanish slang and fast talking and I have
trouble understanding that like I put the
Spanish subtitles on to be able to see what
they're saying cause that's very unclear for
me. But like Argentinian Spanish, just because
it's what I grew up around is super easy to
understand.
Yeah, that's really interesting to hear. Okay.
Thank you for answering my question, David.
Have a good day.
All right, you too. Thank you for the call.